fundamentally the most common thing you
would get at the beginning before you
got somebody really
excited for you for whatever reason is
uh
they would open the meeting like this
you know i don't really have a place for
you
i don't really have a place for you this
is the opening of the meeting so you sat
down hey alex how you doing great nice
to meet you so
so you were in america yes yeah i did
this little thing yes great god i love
that director yeah you have me too
me too i he's great um and
fundamentally you just really want to
say so listen what are we doing here
what's the point of this do you want me
do you not want me
i want the meeting to go like that what
do you want to do
i want to i wish it was more direct but
anyway so the opening statement would be
this
then we'd get through all the niceties
and then i
i don't have i'm not gonna be able to
take you and then we go on for another
40 minutes of a meeting that's a real
horrible feeling because at that point
for me i just want to say you know what
that's cool i respect that that's your
choice i'd like to leave now
but you can't do that so you have to sit
there and do this ridiculousness for
another half an hour
as you're sitting there going i have to
talk to you after you just told me you
want nothing to do with me
so yeah so those were annoying things